welcome to this video playing concrete
from Turkey so let's see do we get the
tribe for the time on off without really
knowing what i'm doing but ok i'll
probably lead to interesting games yeah
a queen have three years the latest
trend there ok f4 hmm yeah that's a
that's an interesting line that i don't
know i know that they play it in recent
years just tried with normal moose Steve
55 doesn't that look kind of good the
night before is that bad hmm why yes to
give his bishop but maybe yeah maybe my
e for porn is getting to be a problem
guy anyway 97 looks kinda silly now so
let's jump right in
why is he not taking immediately that's
kind of strange okay so yeah that's
interesting before I am Gavin if I go
Bishop a five he might just go before
yeah that looks that looks kind of
uncomfortable really is some Bishop d7
is going Quincy five oopsie ain't ya
okay well it shows that I don't know
that opening that looks already kind of
wrong yeah okay maybe it may it's not
that bad
interesting i 495 okay and that's your
five is close to picking up that pawn
and that something I should have seen
seen I was just thinking night c 5 i'm
dropping dropping back to see eight or
something okay interesting
check yeah I lost that porn and he's got
a pretty nice position yeah not not good
really not
yeah it's always tricky if you try out a
new opening line that you don't know and
someone plays a dangerous sideline it's
it's tricky I steven got 9 Bishop d8 has
a very strange move but could be good
cannot move the Queen and the night
after that that's a pretty good move
actually yeah I saw it he saw it
well
yeah I didn't see anything good I mean
you can still just play Quincy for
something like that or that move
yeah it's strong e 7 is just detect
multiple times
hi tech can I somehow get out of this I
don't see it really maybe I can look the
Queen next move for 2 f2 or something
what g5 even can I go g5 so wreaks a lot
of desperation but
check
96
I mean 96 I can take it and I cannot
move them look that bad here maybe I can
then he can take Jennifer and check me
on da check check okay black resins me
now care seems like a legit account okay
so job that was a bad opening result
really probably that d 5 and 94 is not
good I I don't know it was just like I
added I didn't know what to do and this
is not good simply either dark squares
are very weak and he played a very
plated in a very strong way I think this
is all jack all strong the a bishop da
that was the key move I mean of course
I'm worth in any case now but if I'm not
playing 97 I can at least fight but this
is a strong move I mean I saw it as well
but just just too late after that I'm
lost simply there's no way m to get get
around that check around that pin so
yeah this is something that has to be
repaired right in the opening probably d
594 size is bad but I really have no
idea how this this line has to be has to
be handled it's that's difficult that
kind of sharp opening play is difficult
to handle over the board in a blitz game
if you don't know what happens really
and the other guy has some just playing
his son learned theory that's that's
difficult then okay well thanks for
watching